Olha só que absurdo. Tão dizendo por aí
que Coca-Cola com batata frita cu
xaqueca. Pois é, eu vi essa barbaridade
no TikTok, preciso falar sobre isso,
gente. Isso é o cúmulo do absurdo
médico. Veja bem, a medicina funcional
busca a causa da sua enxaqueca. Pode ser
deficiência de magnésio, desequilíbrio
hormonal, inflamação intestinal,
intolerância alimentar. E o que que essa
solução faz? Joga mais veneno no seu
corpo. Refrigerante é puro açúcar
refinado que inflama seu intestino e
dispara sua insulina. batata frita, óleo
oxidado, acrilamida, gordura trans, tudo
que piora a inflamação neurológica. A
cafeína até pode dar um alívio
momentâneo, mas você tá mascarando o
problema e criando dependência. Sem
falar que esses alimentos ultra
processados são gatilhos conhecidos para
enxaqueca. Quer resolver de verdade?
Investiga deficiências nutricionais,
melhora o seu sono, controla o seu
estresse, identifica seus gatilhos
alimentares.